artificial intelligence is changing the
world around us those who can harness
the power of AI will have the tools to
unlock rich new business opportunities
in every industry but what are these new
opportunities industries are looking for
knowledgeable product managers but few
product managers have AI experience the
new AI product manager nanodegree
program from Udacity prepare students
for life is AI product managers giving a
baseline understanding in major AI
fields teaching students how to build AI
power products and bring value to their
business using AI you shall learn how to
identify business opportunities for AI
and create metrics to evaluate the
success of potential AI products you'll
learn to build AI models using automated
machine learning and the best part is
there's no coding required you'll build
models using Google auto ml and they
will unique datasets and figure Eight's
data annotation platform AI is changing
our world and its impact on future
products will unlock vast new
opportunities be at the forefront of AI
revolution enroll new dasa t's AI
product manager nanodegree program today
you
[Music]